Lovesick, head over heels,
butterflies in the tummy.
We all have ways of describing
what love feels like,
but what is actually going on
in our brains when we fall in love?
And how do we know how to distinguish
lust from love?
According to Helen E Fisher,
from Rutgers University,
there are three aspects
of romantic love.
Often lust comes first,
but not always.
For some people who are asexual,
it may not happen at all.
But for those who do experience lust,
it's driven by the hormones
oestrogen and testosterone.
They affect our libido,
the sex drive.
It may feel purely carnal, but
in fact it's about the urge to mate
and pass on your DNA via offspring.
Without lust, it's fair to say
our species would not survive.
The second aspect of romantic love
is attraction,
influenced by a neurotransmitter
called dopamine.
This is a feel-good substance
released in our brain
that is involved in driving us
towards reward.
Do something, get a dopamine hit,
feel good.
Eventually dopamine will push us
toward repeating that behaviour.
This is why intense attraction
feels like an addiction
to another human being.
Some people get stuck in that loop,
always chasing the
dopamine-soaked excitement
of a new relationship.
Might as well face it -
you're addicted to love.
Dopamine also dampens
the region of the brain
that regulates critical thinking
and rational behaviour.
People often stay in this somewhat
irrational honeymoon period
for up to 18 months.
Another hormone that plays a role
in attraction is norepinephrine
which is involved in generating
the physiological responses
we experience in this state.
Think sweaty palms, heart fluttering,
breathing faster.
In that sense, strong attraction
is similar to a state of stress,
but it's good stress,
because we associate these sensations
with positive things
such as the sight, sound,
or even the smell of our lover.
The third aspect is attachment
or bonding.
There are two other hormones at work
here, oxytocin and vasopressin.
Oxytocin, known as
the cuddle hormone,
is released during sex
and skin-to-skin contact.
This heightens feelings of security
and contentment
which help forge deep bonds
with a mate.
In some people, negative
experiences as a child
can affect the oxytocin system
making it harder for them
to form attachments as adults.
But thankfully, with the right kind
of therapy, our brains can be rewired
to form healthy relationships.
As for vasopressin, this is released
directly after having sex
and it too produces feelings
of contentment.
This may have a taming effect
on more promiscuous people
by triggering the
neural reward system,
encouraging you to want to stay
with the person you love.
And all being well, with time,
love can morph into something
stable and fulfilling.
Research has shown that kindness
plays a key role.
You could say that a long-term bond
is a continuous exercise in kindness.
Of course, love can also
have a darker side.
Obsessive, jealous behaviours
can be intensified
by falling levels of serotonin,
a mood-levelling hormone.
And we all know that love
doesn't always last,
and when it doesn't, it hurts.
Heartbreak is real.
It's known as broken heart syndrome
and can even be mistaken
for a heart attack.
The emotional stress that
accompanies break-ups
releases chemicals that usually
signal physical pain,
so our brain interprets the break-up
as intensely painful.
But despite the heartbreaks,
the sweaty palms,
and the irrational behaviour,
people fall in love and stay in love
every minute of every day.
Because those dopamine hits
can feel amazing.
So even if it doesn't always
feel like it,
the head really does rule the heart.